- [Jasmine] Teaspoon lemon lemons.
(squishing sound)
- What a sound.
What is wrong with that juicer?
Hey, guys, it's Katie.
And we are back with another
translation challenge.
If you haven't been here before,
what we do is we take a recipe,
we put it into Google Translate,
we go from English to German, to Japanese,
to Arabic, to Zulu,
and many, many more, all
the way back to English
to give us this hilariously
translated recipe.
Last time, Jasmine pulled a fast one on me
and made me do it.
She's not gonna get away with that today.
I have made the translation
pretty hard today
as a little bit of payback.
So, let's get in there
and give her her surprise.
Okay, Jasmine.
(air whooshing)
- Oh, I'm scared.
- This is a simpler recipe
sent in by you guys.
- Oh, thanks guys.
- But I made the translation really hard.
- Oh, no!
(both laughing)
- Payback!
- Oh no!
- You'll be great, you still get clues.
You still get everything.
(paper rustling)
(both laughing)
- "Farm on the Moon."
- Isn't it so fun?
- It's so fun!
- It's like a David Bowie song.
♪ I'm on a farm on the moon. ♪
Don't read any other things.
- I no read.
- Let's get started.
- Okay.
- Step one, add half cup
water, one copy joker,
and put where to put in the pot?
- This is what happens, this is payback.
(Katie laughing)
- Copy joker.
Copy sheet!
One sheet joker.
Funny, funny, joker, joker, card.
One sheet, sheet, one-
- What's happening?
- I'm trying to think out loud.
Half cup water,
but where to put?
Put in pot?
(clanking sound)
Pot.
- She's really gonna hit someone.
(Katie laughing)
- If step two is not easier, like you.
- [Katie] It's not.
Um, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, water.
(Jasmine grunting)
That's a lot of,
that's a lot of water.
Add half cup water.
I'm adding half little cup of water
and put where to put in the pot.
One cup, one cup, joker,
joker, joker, joker.
- Anything coming to mind?
- Solitaire.
Clown, milk.
I'm gonna go with sugar.
- Why are you doing sugar?
- Because if it's gonna be savory,
it's fine if there's some sugar,
it'll be like, mm, sweet and savory.
And I'm gonna stick with a cup.
Is it right?
I don't know.
So I assume I'm making some
simple syrup right now.
Step two, find the answer
and look until juicy.
Find the answer means like maybe like...
(Jasmine laughing)
- Are you scared?
What's happening?
- I'm shutting down.
- You are.
You're like a robot.
- I'm gonna find my hot plate.
- So you think the recipe
line was find your hot plate?
- I don't know.
I think it's like stir
until sugar has dissolved.
I'm choosing to put it on a hot plate
and stir until it becomes syrupy.
Okay, this looks juicy to me.
Let's move on to the next step.
Step number three, turn the flame over,
and one teaspoon what is it lemon, lemon.
Quarter teaspoon cadmium
and a pinch of garlic?!
What?!
Okay, so turn off the heat.
- So how do you know
it's turned off the heat?
- I don't and one teaspoon, what is it?
Lemon, lemon.
Lemon.
(bell dinging)
I'm gonna roll this so
it's nice and juicy.
- You think it's lemon lemon?
(Jasmine laughing)
No, I'm just asking.
So lemon lemon is lemon juice?
- Yes.
- Okay.
- I'm just gonna eyeball
a teaspoon lemon, lemon.
(crew laughing)
(squishing sound)
- What is wrong with that juicer?
What a sound.
- Quarter teaspoon cadmium
and a pinch of garlic.
What's cadmium?
- It's a metal.
- Is it, really?
Why am I talking like this?
(Katie laughing)
I'm nervous.
All right, let's look at these spices.
Saffron, celery salt, how fun.
Cardamom!
- Wait, why did you get excited?
- It sounds like cadmium.
Which is a perfect way to throw me off.
I think I'm gonna ask for a hint.
- Who would you like a hint from.
- Kelly.
(Jasmine laughing)
- Kelly, Kelly.
I have terrible hands.
All right, Kelly, go for it.
- I'm just gonna say you
were on the right track
when you picked something up.
- Dang it!
Cardamom.
Let's add a quarter teaspoon of cadmium,
which I'm choosing to be cardamom
and a pinch of garlic.
I actually wanna say it
should be a pinch of salt.
Who says pinch of garlic?
Nobody.
(Kelly laughing)
- Wait, what?
Nobody.
- Nobody.
Let's mince some garlic, shall we?
- So how did you come to this conclusion?
- Well, I wanted to do a pinch of salt,
but I don't see any salt on the table.
So I am going with garlic.
It's not gonna make it worse.
Garlic only makes things better.
- Have you ever made
anything like this before?
- With this amount of sugar,
I feel like it's some sort of like sauce
for meat or something.
(chopping sound)
- [Katie] Look how good
you are at your mincing.
- So I don't know how finely minced
this is supposed to be, right?
- [Katie] I could not tell you.
Are you adding all that?
- I'll just add what's on the knife.
(buzzer ringing)
Pinch of garlic and a little more.
Now mine's gonna taste
better than the original.
- [Katie] Oh, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay, okay!
- Step four, taken.
Where's Liam Neeson?
(Jasmine laughing)
- She was like, "Taken."
Wow!
- I just, you know,
what was I gonna do with the extra?
- I'm proud of you.
- A pinch of garlic means
five cloves of garlic.
You know what I think taken
means, put it to the side.
Step five, one cup of wheat flour,
two tablespoon chicken breasts Marcus
and quarter teaspoon
yellow is the color of food
in a blender.
- Who's Marcus?
I don't know Marcus.
(Katie laughing)
- One cup of wheat flour.
Wheat flour?
Does it have to be wheat flour?
Is that a trick?
Should that actually be regular flour?
I didn't know this existed.
Coconut flour.
I'm gonna go all purpose.
(plastic rustling)
I just feel like you can never go wrong.
And if it's not, I think it'll be okay.
I would like a hint for
chicken breasts, Marcus.
- From?
- Mimo.
(Jasmine laughing)
- Okay, Mimo, do you have a hint?
Save your chicken breast for Marcus.
(Katie laughing)
That was very cryptic actually.
I think Mimo might be
giving to worst hint.
(Jasmine laughing)
- I don't want any of
those hints anymore, okay?
Save your chicken breast for later.
- No.
All right, here's your new hint.
Chicken is not the only chick.
- Peas.
- Chick, what?
(Katie laughing)
- [Katie] Okay.
So, what are you gonna do?
- Chickpeas, chickpeas, coconut milk.
- That's not chickpeas.
- Besan!
Also known as garbanzo or chickpea flour.
Okay, quarter teaspoon
yellow is the color of food
in a blender.
Okay, ah, you know what?
I'm just gonna go yellow.
Why not, I love yellow.
It was one of my favorite colors.
And if I'm wrong, that's
okay, I've been wrong before.
Let's add a quarter teaspoon
of yellow food coloring.
I'm just gonna eyeball it.
Perhaps mixing is fine.
(woman laughing)
Next step, mix one cup of milk
and half cup of water and drink
until the cough is strong.
One cup milk.
Does it have to be a
specific kind of milk?
I'm gonna go with oat
milk because I like it.
Okay, one cup milk.
(buzzer ringing)
Okay, half cup water.
(bell dinging)
I'm making a batter?
Until the cough is strong.
Until the batter is thick.
I'm doing a little mixie mix.
(bell dinging)
Step seven, if you don't
agree with the battery,
add one teaspoon of lemon juice.
Battery is better?
- Hmm, hmm.
- Hmm, hmm, hmm.
(Katie and Jasmine laughing)
If I don't agree.
Well, I find that it's agreeable.
Add one teaspoon of lemon juice.
I will just add a little bit, like half,
half a teaspoon of lemon juice.
Step eight, then add the
best half teaspoon soda
and stir head of state.
The best baking soda, I presume.
We only have the best
baking soda here at "Tasty."
So I stir head of state.
Step number nine, push the hook
into the pressure cylinder.
Pressure cylinder.
Woo!
- Do you feel good?
You think that's it?
- Yeah!
Look at my beautiful batter.
(bell dinging)
- [Katie] Beautiful, gorgeous.
- A part of me thinks
that this could be, like,
some sort of pancake batter.
Step number 10, fill the barbecue
mold with one inch of oil,
reduce the heat.
I'm going with an inch of oil in this pot.
Reduce the heat, simmer.
Step 11, pour the flour
into the milk to prepare.
The flour will rise
quickly, but not black.
Pour the flour into the oil.
The batter will rise quickly,
but, oh, don't burn it!
I'm gonna wait till the oil gets hot
and then I'll move on to the next step.
Step number 12, make a small
town with a mixture of yeast,
hot spiral, hard oil.
I think this is the hot spiral.
The...
(hissing sound)
I'll do a spiral.
(sizzling sound)
(buzzer ringing)
That was not a spiral.
I think I need to add more flour to this.
(Jasmine laughing)
Looks like ramen.
It looks like a bunch of
seahorses hanging out.
Step 13, cook until both are gone.
What does that mean?
It's burning.
I don't know what's happening.
I must have messed up somewhere.
I'm gonna give spiral a try again.
Okay, great, second try.
(woman laughing)
- [Katie] Kelly's eyes are twitching
'cause she's nervous for you.
- Step 14, take the juice and immediately.
I think I need a hint.
- Yeah?
- This batter consistency is not correct.
Katie.
- Yes.
- Can you help me?
- Here's my hint to you, make
a small town, not a big town,
like a big town.
- It's just so runny.
I don't even know if I can make a town.
- Just try to make a little town.
- [Jasmine] Okay.
- That's new.
(Katie laughing)
- That's new, thank you.
Well, you know what?
- [Katie] I like that one.
- 14, take the juice and immediately.
Take the juice, immediately!
'Cause it's hot.
You pour it over.
So I was right.
Remember, I guess this earlier?
I made a flying saucer.
- [Katie] It's so cool, I like it.
- I guess I'll just make more of these.
'Cause I'd rather eat that than this.
I'm just gonna do one
more big one like this
and then I will move on to the next step.
It's reminding me of funnel cake,
this mess I'm making.
- What if it is funnel cake?
- Maybe then I messed up.
(Katie laughing)
- I kind of regret pranking you
because you made this a lot harder.
I'm done, that's my last one.
So I think I'm just gonna put
some squigglies on the bottom
for some height.
These can take the residual juices.
Ooh!
- Are those your small towns?
- My small town, big town.
Yummy!
Oh, the juice.
Okay, my garlic sugar.
(buzzer ringing)
I'm pouring it over.
- [Katie] Ooh.
(Katie laughing)
It looks otherworldly, right?
- Step 15, solved.
Yeah, it is!
(bell dinging)
Works, yeah it does!
(Katie laughing)
Enjoys for 30 seconds.
Oh, let it soak for 30 seconds
(bell dinging)
and then eat.
I'm finished!
Ta-da!
- Master.
- My master squiggly towns.
Bring in the original.
I'm ready to see it.
"Farm on the Moon."
(Jasmine sniffing)
Mine smell like garlic.
(scraping sound)
(Jasmine sniffing)
- [Katie] Open your eyes!
(Jasmine laughing)
- Okay, this has been my biggest fail yet.
- [Katie] No, no!
Do you want to know what the name is?
- Yeah!
- Okay, it's jalebi.
- Oh, jalebi!
- Yes and it is an Indian dessert.
- [Jasmine] Let's try
a "Farm on the Moon."
(crunching sound)
Mm!
Oh, my God.
- Really?!
- Yeah!
The garlic is amazing.
Phenomenal, I'm not even kidding.
- [Katie] Really?!
- I'm dead serious.
- Wow!
- All right, let's try some jalebi.
My batter was definitely not thick enough
to make a shape like this.
Was I wrong with the milk?
- The milk was wrong.
It was supposed to be yogurt.
- I knew it!
(crunching sound)
Mm, mm, delicious but different.
I'm very impressed with the shape.
It's just beautiful.
Entrée, dessert.
This was really fun.
Make sure to keep sending
recipes to Katie on Instagram
@oldladiekatie and maybe
a little easier next time?
- Maybe, we'll see.
(Katie laughing)
- Bye, guys!
- Bye!
- [Andrew] Oh, yes!
(upbeat music)